hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Friday the 13th is now on disk the smart
players will be joining us at Crystal
Lake in the hopes of escaping Jason with
that in mind I thought we should outline
10 tips to be the best Jason you can and
make your mother proud there's no
definitive way to play Jason but with
any look this will make newcomers better
equipped from the outset and those of
you who are veterans hopefully there'll
be things in here you haven't considered
yet okay let's do this before Jason goes
on the attack it's best to think
defensively usually the fastest way for
counselors to escape is by calling the
cops and waiting out the five minutes to
be rescued this drastically cuts down
the massacre time so one of the first
things every Jason should do is teleport
over to the phone icon on the map and
set up a few traps around the relay box
the survivors will need to repair you
will be alerted by any truck being
trodden on so quickly pulling out your
map and checking which of the traps has
now vanished then fast traveling to that
location you can prevent the police from
spoiling your fun
still thinking defensively a solid next
step to take is to set up trapped around
other objectives are more specifically
the cars and the boat again this is all
about getting the drop on potential
escapees in fact let's jump to the next
general point listen like we've already
said you can hear when traps have caught
someone but not only that listen and you
will hear when a car have been started
or if someone messes up in one of those
minigames
the cells can be easy to miss so listen
to the alerts keep your ears open and be
ready to jump to a location fast
speaking of listening to your
surroundings the stock function allows
you to turn the tables on the counselors
I'm sure you're completely aware of
musical changes when Jason is near a
counselor the intensity rises and they
tend to scatter like rabbits using stock
you can disable this feature so when
used correctly the counselors can be
fooled into thinking they are safe as no
music is playing only for Jason to pop
up unexpectedly
causing a jump-scare and buying you a
little bit more time to murder those
pesky counselors let's quickly talk
about the best practice ways of using
some of the other abilities Jason has
sense allows you to see your foes in red
depending on the distance and fear my
tip isn't when to use it my tip is to
turn it off quickly let it regenerate
use it quickly to identify a target then
turn it off again and save it this
technique will let Jason use sense
multiple times every minute which is
very useful indeed the shift ability can
be a little difficult to use at times a
steering can be a pain in the backside
but once you've mastered it a shorter
shift and grout try to surprise an enemy
it seems obvious but you'll be surprised
how many times I've seen adjacent
shifting around in circles waiting for
it to end
[Music]
thia is vital to a good horror film and
the same goes for the game finding ways
to strike fear in the hearts of the
counselors is a useful tactic some
counselors will be scared stiff by
seeing your ugly mug others require a
little bit more to be a screaming mess
to help the fear along try to take out
the electricity boxes at each of the
busier areas of the map this knocks out
all the lighting and not only does the
fear level rise but it also makes
survivors use their torch which in turn
makes your job a little easier to search
and destroy at some point you'll be
stuck in an annoying chase with a
counselor that runs in circles this
feels like a huge waste of time but
eventually you will catch up with them
to speed things up a little crack out
those throwing knifes these projectiles
can be used to interrupt the healing
animation of counselors - and others
depending on the moment they are thrown
right as you become Jason grab those
throwing knives and try to pick up as
many as you can on your journeys but
don't go out of your way to find them if
you've been a little unlucky and the
police have been called plant traps
around the exit point most players are
very aware of this technique so bury
where you place them the road may be a
little obvious for some veteran players
so try the bushes and the places
counselors sneak through this links to
my next point
don't always grab the counselors use
your weapon during the latter stages a
few survivors will have pockets knives
to stun you the second you grab them to
counteract this swing your weapon like
your madman
this method can sometimes be quicker to
kill and the last time watching an
execution is better you slicing up
another victim finally in the latter
stages of each game you will find
yourself looking for a sole survivor
usually around one of the bigger
buildings
you've broken down all the beds and
wardrobes but you still can't find them
your next step is to look for
unconventional hiding spots a counselor
can just sit behind the door a counselor
can be up against a wall in between
units a counselor can even be on the
outside of a building but so close to it
that it appears they are on the inside
so try not to get frustrated and be
vigilant so there you go there's 10 tips
to be the best Jason you can
thanks for taking the time to watch this
and if you have any strategies or best
practices then let us know in the
comments oh and a huge welcome to all of
you who have recently bought Friday the
13th I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
you